hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's sister location now I did that
thing in the last episode where I start
a bunch of thoughts and I don't finish
him because I'm in a blind panic and I
have no idea what I'm doing and
everything is going all kerfuffled
around me and just trying to survive
so I didn't think things through so in
this thing which is a spring lock type
animatronic which is very bizarre number
one because why is that here in not
Freddy fazbear's pizzeria why is that a
leftover thing but also these things
that were crawling up the side I totally
forgot that I can wiggle yeah I know I
know
and also my wiggling I know and my
wiggling
I got you so I did not know that I could
wiggle so I think it's going to be a
balance of wiggling versus knocking
these things often I don't know where
they are is when crawling up already it
is so yeah wiggle haha that was correct
that was absolutely correct so I just
need to strike a balance and actually
use my brain and try to no get off of
here
so I'm gonna get this oh my god that wig
oh geez that is not good that's not good
I can hear you clambering up my leg rich
okay so just got a hold this down and
planky dank my way I thought I heard him
I wants to shook him off all the way
down so what I want to know is what room
am I in where am I in this world like
they were looking for me which meant
that there are some people employers
somewhere around here and I don't know
who they might be or or what they're
doing but whoever it is is the person
that's looking on the security cameras
so some other human person
oh geez oh geez how close was that to
killing me oh jeez probably extremely
and I don't want to know exactly how
close but probably a lot close geez this
is a constant battle hey OH
wagging I was wobbled jabbing okay that
didn't work I didn't pay attention to
them crawling up my grundle all right
let's try this again but I know the
general strategy so we're gonna get
pretty far now hopefully oh man you know
what this is remem innocent of it's
reminiscent of the the music box you
know the first from five nights at
freddys to constantly keeping the music
box wound and then having to flip back
and forth between the two of them I
don't even hear them crawling up I'm
just gonna have to guess that they're
crawling up every like 20 seconds or so
and then tried to do something about
that but I still don't know if I'm gonna
have enough time to be able to do all
this [ __ ] so I got to be really precise
about where my mouse goes from flit to
flit and oh man that knocks everything
so I can't do that unnecessarily which I
just did
to try to shake something off that I
don't even know if there was something
there so I'm [ __ ] I gotta like go back
and forth between them because I can't
just do I can't just do on one side I
gotta be quick oh Jesus no I see you
there whoa whoa hey whoa what God [ __ ]
what I was wailing oh god not again I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to do
this
[Music]
oh okay
alrighty then I still don't know what
that's about and I don't know why I'm
doing that but I'm doing it and I'm
doing it for you because I love you
whom dying so I still don't know how to
figure out like how do you how do you
bash him off when they're coming up the
front there was two coming up the front
wait there there he is he came so what
the [ __ ] what was that
[Music]
so I just need to not mind them crawling
inside my suit here and I'm gonna die
these are these are this bad dis bad
that's very bad is what you would call
real real real real real real real bad
I'm fob or not I'm fob or not gonna Bob
or not so you just you just don't look
at him it's the thing jeez how are you
not supposed to look at things crawling
inside your suit oh god I'm dead I'm so
dead there's there's literally no way
there's literally no way
how in the hell what do I do
holy [ __ ] I can't that's insane that's
insanity how in the hell are you
supposed to do that oh man holy crap I
don't I don't know if I understand this
I don't know if I understand anything is
going to Hawaii
don't mind me not looking at you why
would I be looking at you why would
anybody looking at your ugly face oh boy
there's another one okay I'm not gonna
be able to
how how how in the heck how in the heck
e heck how in the Frick damn heck how in
the heck e Hecky maybe it's not maybe
it's not that you can't look at them
maybe it's that you can't wiggle when
there's one crawling in I think that
might be it but holy heck e heck this is
getting obscenely difficult like wowie
Zowie who P paui see that one's crawls
right in and that's fine I guess don't
mind that a little weird but I mean I
guess I don't mind it I get to
supposedly be like a sense of unease
considering they're literally going into
my suit here it's my private area but so
I'm gonna try to wait I'm not gonna get
them like right off the bat because
number one I got people crawling up the
sides anyway so there he goes okay this
is a bit more manageable I think I can I
think I can deal with this okay so now
when they're coming up now and they're
coming up old geezers more and more and
more I got my eye on you [ __ ] okay it
was okay
apparently walking there's so many of
them so goddamn many of them is now we
got a lot on well on alert on alert
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] we are in truck we're [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] are you supposed to be
able to do this how in the following
[ __ ] like honestly though there's no way
would you people do that how would
anybody am i missing the key component
here cuz holy [ __ ] okay I think there
might be a significant benefit to
getting them all the way wound as
opposed to only partially and then
moving on because it seems to stay wound
for a little bit longer when you get him
all the way up which is good all things
considered so I think this is the only
way that you're gonna be able to survive
is just if you do all of these all the
way up because otherwise you're just a
whole lot of boned and that's no good
yep losing battle now is this oh there's
no way god damn it it's just no way I
just don't see how it's feasible there
really is something like not evident
here cuz there doesn't seem like it's
it's it's an exercise of time right like
how long I'm gonna I'm gonna actually do
a timer just because like a stopwatch
and I'm at a time from the first moment
that I can do this I can find you on the
camera I'm going to recommend max okay
so I'm timing this to try to get a
general sense of like if I can last a
long time and then fail I'll know
exactly like what I need to do but you
know it just doesn't seem like it's
something and I'm going back and forth
because there seems to be like something
else that's causing me to die if I stay
looking only at one side for a while and
I don't know what that's about but you
know I'm just trying to try to get by
and we're just starting to lose it this
is where everything starts to go past
the
where you can really keep it up with so
you can't exactly get everything to full
you know and we just crossed two minutes
right there so if I had to guess it's
probably like any other five nights at
freddys night and you have to last six
minutes but I don't see how anybody with
the amount of wiggling that you have to
do I don't see how anybody could last
six full minutes here because it just
seems like an impossibility unless we're
going to three because it seems like I
might fail like somewhere close to three
minutes but with the amount of wiggling
that you have to do especially Elector
the end here like it's just a little too
much for like someone to be able to
handle but I'm gonna try to get to three
full minutes here but this wiggle is
gonna kill me
yep that will kill me which we might be
but even so with the amount of wiggling
it's just like a little too much
wiggling unless you have to wait for
like that them to get to the very
tip-top because they get up
pretty dang high before you die from
them so maybe you have to wait until
like you get a double so you only wiggle
like one time and that'll be just enough
to save you in the end but we're all
I'll try that method and then see how
high we can get because that seems like
the only possible solution here because
that guy's climbing up I can obviously
see that so I'm gonna let him get as
high as possible and then bingo bango
bongo got two of them okay so that's
good got to at once to four combo I'll
always take that ones over there
two's over there okay so there's two of
them definitely two of them poink that
one takes four I think I distinctly
remember that happening to like the last
time I was over there it took four as
well but I'm just not a hundred percent
sure about anything at this point but
I'm just gonna try to let him get as
high as possible we just crossed to a
minute 30
so we're doing okay but I know it's
about now is when it starts to fall
apart because there's really no
recovering after a certain point at 220
right now
Oh God how far was that along see I let
him get super high but that guy came
along and just [ __ ] up my day
dammit okay this is stressful not dead
yet
we're damn close [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
three minutes oh god yes what do I just
go home after this what do I just shovel
popcorn in three minutes is what it was
I'm taking the car the joke's on you
it's a rental joke's on you I set the
thermostat to 90 before I left good I
like it warm good because I also set the
house on fire
oh the passion the tension in three tune
in tomorrow for the exciting conclusion
ah okay then so we did that holy [ __ ]
that was like really difficult for being
in the main game night for there that's
really tough it's secret what you say I
got stopped talking up and back to your
last day on the job yeah is the last day
of your first week some of the most
valued qualities that we like to see a
new employees are determination
fearlessness and a genuine disregard for
instinctive self-preservation
you've earned your one week bonus which
will be given to you in the form of a
delightful gift basket
cost of which will be taken out of your
next paycheck if baskets containing
fruit nuts flowers and of course the
ever-popular cash basket using the
keypad below please enter the first few
letters of the gift basket you would
like to receive well it doesn't matter
if I get the cash basket you're only
gonna take it out of my goddamn picture
and you had some trouble with the keypad
I see what you were trying to type and I
will autocorrect it for you thank you
for selecting exotic butters yeah
actually that sounds ok me do love some
butter I love good home where there are
still two technicians on site today try
to avoid interfering with their work if
possible also feel free to ask them why
they are still there and encourage them
to go home what wait there's two other
technicians here are they alive that's
my first question
if I only get twenty questions here my
first one is gonna be are they alive or
am I gonna find their dead ass in the
middle of the goddamn vent I have no
idea if I am but either way I think I'm
out of time for this episode I've really
been plowing through this one it took a
long long long time to get through that
of repetitive relentlessness to it which
is surprising considering it's only
night four but now we're going into
night five so yeah we can find out a
little bit more I'm gonna get to the
other room first and then we're gonna
end it here because I want to I realize
I've been doing the same thing for a
long time I want to see like just a
little bit of what else is here if there
is some of them if there is something
else story-wise I want to get a bit more
story before I leave you guys cuz I hate
to just be like army try me let's check
on boo Laura and make sure she's on her
stage yeah okay how about that
all right now let's check on fun time
foxy great it looks like everything is
as it should be in fun time auditorium
your test today will involve more
maintenance work circus baby had a rough
day and is in need of repair you will be
required to reach the parts and service
room by once again sneaking through fun
time auditorium as always please proceed
with caution Oh God okay so that's the
next thing that I need to do and I'm not
gonna do that so I know where the two
other technicians are there so either
way that is all that I'm gonna do for
this one I'm gonna finish this up or
quote-unquote finish it up because we
all know the knight 5 is never the last
night in the next video so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know how I did now in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]